said that love has an expiry date how do
you guys feel oh on that oh I agree I'm
medium I think love is a Young Person's
game the average person only falls in
love like three times so you really
don't have that many shots at it
um
see the type of love that
wait how many loves are there can you
find it Pearl this Eros love there's
there's like three separate types of
love I don't know okay I think yeah
because I don't want to quote it wrong
um but I know there's there's different
types of love and I'm gonna toe the type
of love that we want but essentially any
girl that I want like that I want a
future with I want to marry I want to be
my girlfriend the type of love she has
to have for me the type of love to have
for my for my brothers and the reason I
say this is is
we can fight we can go back whatever but
at no point is are we ever going to
break the relationship up between my
brothers and
some guys you you know you won't keep
all friends but for the day ones you're
always gonna fix it even when you're mad
even when this like even if when you
don't speak something is going to bring
the two of you to fix it because you
know that's that deep love when you let
it go too far you know when you get let
it go too far between the and then you
and then you don't speak to someone and
maybe you Buck up to them one time then
you maybe try to you know let's go out
again bro you it's not the same love
that's what happens with relationships
it just takes one person not to give up
as soon as one person says I'm gonna
give up that's it it's all over so I
just I need that type of love that got
all my Bros and my family there's four
types of Love Eros which is erotic
passionate love um filler which is love
of friends and equals uh storage
um love of parents for children and
Agape the love of mankind okay so yeah
so the I was talking about this it was a
second one the love of friends is that
the one I was talking about love
um love of friends and equals it can be
the love between lovers when they've
been together for a long time and are
not so hot and bothered anymore it's
called brotherly love is the city of
Philadelphia the City of Brotherly Love
of course it could be sisterly love but
it is the accepting love of good
friendship that is the love that is your
for good health the love of the touch of
a loved one the fill a lot like lowers
blood pressure yeah you get the idea
that's the love and that's the love all
the mother loves not fate but all their
mother loves our based upon sign that
full of love is the one where's your
Bros and you're gonna yeah you're not
it's not it's never gonna break and it's
the and the one and the love only gets
stronger it doesn't fade and that's the
that's the love that that relationship
need the Lesser love that I would want
but in this day and age I I was saying
when we had our conversation I feel like
there's an expiry date on love because
it's like you love me until when I can I
can do something and then you'll just
give up on the love and then that's it
the situation is done you're you're now
saying that you're gonna move on and
start chatting to other guys just
because a situation happened this is why
I don't know if I could get married
because it's like I could do something
maybe do something that you don't like
and then you're just gonna stop loving
me because of that situation so it's
like there's an expiry date or love you
love me until when are you pressed
why do you say that are you pressed
because me and me and Kyle was speaking
about this I had to let him understand
that
to an extent I understand love has an
expiry date but it wouldn't have had
that expiry date if he but I was gonna
hold me back
wait say it say if he what say that
again it's just a little bit of
pettiness put it this way I felt like
the reason why while I was looking at it
like when we were speaking about it I
wouldn't have had an expiration date for
Kyle if I felt chosen okay sorry Paul
this is the alpha Widow scenario I'm I'm
picking up on it like because the people
because he can't be your friend he can't
be your friend
no no because you're not over this like
it's like even what you've just said you
just like I didn't even realize we're
about to go back to you and him again no
he was having a healthy no but it is
healthy but there's something awesome if
he's pressed you just ask him he's
impressed no because I was wondering is
coming from like reality respectable
okay well then yeah I'm I'm everything
you guys say no but no but see what
happened there this is why me as a man I
would not have him yeah as your friend
because already you're thinking back to
Memories now or things like you guys
this is too much this is too close and
I'm not insecure but I know a red flag
when I see it yeah and if I and if I I'm
just gonna be honest with you because
this is a this is education for you yeah
when you meet the guy that you like bro
you're gonna have to don't even wait for
her to do it you do a favor for her and
just step there I would do it yeah
because I've done it the last time but
then obviously like the brother was cool
he's from the ends and it was like there
was no situation in it he knew me from
that we have other friends outside of
that so we've seen it but men lie you
know men lie we like possibly possibly I
don't like that girl forget that girl
if he steps away that still doesn't deal
with the issue of what if the boy if the
boyfriend said to her I don't like I
feel comfortable with this friendship
and she wouldn't listen to what he's
saying you've still got that issue and
if a girlfriend won't listen to one
thing there's probably going to be
something later down the line where he
says babes I'm not happy with this and
she goes well
I don't care
and like and this is what I'm trying to
say to you before and because
when you first heard it it sounded like
controlling it sounded like oh you guys
are insecure but when you actually let
it play and you speak about it even you
you probably might you know some things
get brought up you don't even realize
you get annoyed by some people like oh
you're capping that no that's not what
you know what I mean but you should even
care what he's capping about you
shouldn't care about no pettiness you do
you should just be like
but because you've got history and your
families are intertwined literally spoke
about it last week that's why I was like
are you like why are we talking about
this no but it's just a good topic and
based off no it is related to the
conversation hence why I'm mentioning
but I wasn't relating it to us yeah but
bro she loved you and you you you for
every reason you was in the right place
you said it already you was young but
but obviously she was hurt by it you're
someone that she grew up with families
were intertwined he was in a
relationship and then you chose to break
up the relationship and Men typically
don't leave their women I've never ever
left a woman in my life any woman I've
been with left me I'm not saying I
haven't tried to come back afterwards
but men we don't leave our women like I
said the other day if my if I had a baby
with my misses and she put on weight I
think I'll leave her I'll try to make
her go gym I'll try to and if she didn't
want to lose weight I just got a fat
wife that's it you know what it is I'll
be like you know remember the pictures
when you used to be fly I used to be
skinny but I'm not going to leave her no
because she's ready she put was not a
kid for me but but she you know what I'm
trying to say to you like so ah man I
just think I think this is cheating
[Laughter]
I'm honest
what am I doing I just asked the
question but then can we throw it back
to see does love have an expiry I want
to hear everybody's opinion no no you
don't think so no my brother to you
think that love has an expiry date
[Music]
if there's a lot of demand then there's
not true love but if it's true love it
never has an expiry date I think I
misunderstood your question so my
question is does love have an expiry so
I I meant like it does like over a
certain age I don't think it's love I
think it's respect but I don't think
like if you meet that person like I
think it loves a choice so I
misunderstood love is most definitely a
choice I I can agree with you yeah but I
just feel like because I've been in
various relationships it's like as
something can happen and then the woman
will just move different and it's like
you love me until when I'm not saying
I've stepped out or done whatever but
it's like something could happen
something even minuscule and then it's
like the woman will just give up and
then go and be entertained by someone
else so it's like you love me until when
well I think men and women love
differently and I don't think I don't
think women can love men the way men
love women because that's why we're not
when a man is heartbroken it's a lot
harder for him to go for it then I feel
like when a woman is heartbroken I feel
like men deal with heartbreak a lot
harder than women do yeah but I think
men can love like multiple girls at the
same time I I don't know because I think
if a girl's Alpha widowed too hard like
she thinks about that guy like there
there are um
I can't remember if it was like a
comment or where I read this but it was
like a lady in her 80s talking about a
dude she dated when she was in her 17.
like and they interview people on the
streets and they said tell me about your
first love and you just Alpha Widow
Alpha Widow Alpha Widow like I don't
know I think like women it's like
it I don't I don't know which one's
worse because they both have it bad but
I don't think like I think men like have
a heartbreak with everyone with girls
it's like we either never want to talk
to you again and like you're dead like
nothing or like it's like the worst
thing that's ever happened and we'll
talk about it for years fair enough
that's that's my opinion
what do you think what is this question
you guys
um but the thing is you listed four
types of love right
so I don't know if some types of Love
have an expiry date like obviously
love between friends I don't think
really has an expiry date if the
friendship's still going
um that's a tough one I don't think I
could really answer that hey what they
what it love probably the sex one got
expired because
that was probably expire now very steamy
passion all in that business yeah I
think that that probably dies down at
some point like you know I mean just
chilling
you know what I mean
yeah
someone said Jade is still in love with
a Tupac a dead man
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible